some breaking news this evening on the
ongoing scandal around the abuse of team
usa gymnasts and one former coach has
taken his own life after several charges
were laid against him
with more our correspondent in
washington aleister bunkel tell us more
ali
well isabel john gedd was the coach of
the us
women's 2012 olympic gymnastic team
a very successful gymnastic team
nicknamed the fierce five
they took home from those games a number
of medals now
part of the support team was larry
nasser the team
doctor who infamously was sentenced to
many decades
in prison for sexually assaulting
gymnasts and for possessing
child pilot pornography it was a scandal
both across the united states
uh and across the world of sport
john gedd was often linked to
larry nassar and his crimes by some of
nasa's victims
but until today had never actually been
charged with anything
but michigan police charged him this
morning
with 24 crimes including human
trafficking
and child abuse and then this afternoon
the news was reported
that he had taken his own life before
the michigan state
attorney general had managed to give a
press conference and put more details
on record about his charges so within
hours of being charged geddart had taken
his own life that was confirmed by the
michigan attorney general
in a very short statement who said that
his body was found late this afternoon
it was a tragic end to a tragic story
for everyone involved the statement
concluded
okay ali thank you